[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club ten of Africa's
greatest chess players compete in
Abidjan as Vivendi presents the 2018
cote d'ivoire
rapid and glitz Invitational hello chess
fans and welcome back happy Friday
everybody this is the final day of rapid
play in the 2018 Cote d'Ivoire rapid in
glitz my name is Ben Simon joined as
always by Grandmaster Robert Minkowski
Robert you pumped for today I am pumped
yeah things are winding down in the
rapid leg of the tournament and this is
the last chance to really get that edge
going into the glitz portion right
because the games right now are weighted
to points to the one point that we'll
see in the blitz rounds we'll get that
in just a minute and as we are live
right now grandmaster dr. bossom amin is
in the clear first but only by a hair
but let's meet the players so far in
this tournament a lot of them you may
have not heard of before ten players ten
nations represented and a wide variety
of skill levels on the surface but as we
were told yesterday you know a lot of
these players may be underrated we have
the top we have three top players our
top ten in on the entire African
continent this is definitely shaping up
to be a very interesting tournament and
we are only just about halfway through
let's take a look at the tournament
format this is a dual stage tournament
the first stage is rapid play game in 25
with a 10 second delay today we will
complete our first round-robin each game
as I said is worth two points you get
one point for a draw and no points for a
loss today is the final day tomorrow and
Sunday we're going to blitz blitz play
is going to be game in five with a
three-second delay we will see a round
robin
today woohoo a lot of fun each game
though is only worth one point because
these are new games new games compared
to the rapid games yeah Robert but a
little in abundance is a lot yes because
these are gonna be 9 rounds each day
right so that's 9 point points off the
ground so if you do the math there are
the same amount of points total
available for blitz as there are for the
rapid portion is that right I'm not good
at math I think we've over the last
couple of days we've proven that 18 18
total points for the rapid stage
overpays the one full round robin 9
times 2 is 18 and then 18 blitz games is
18 ok so we got to play a lot more games
though so you have to win twice as many
games to get the same amount of points
exactly yeah your potential to gain
points after today slows down
considerably because each game is just
worth going but let's take a look at
where the players stand right now we're
about to start the final rapid round so
after round 8 here's where they are
Robert we have a clear leader yeah and
maybe that incredible save that bossom
amin had yesterday is proving to be that
turning point in the tournament because
yesterday we saw a mean trailing the
field not even in the top three and now
i mean after a couple of nice wins today
that we'll look at in a moment
he has seized the lead and you'll notice
that we are using Universal ratings for
this event the universal rating system
is awfully appropriate for this event
because it is a time it is a rating
system that covers chess played on all
different time controls from as little
as 5 minutes up to 120 it's longer than
128 counts as 120 but you know
discussion for another time this is a
rapid and blitz event so those skills
are incorporated into these numbers so
right now it's to be expected by some I
mean in the lead but it may not be that
way when we end and you know it's very
important to end up in the top five
spots because there are prizes on the
line here this is the richest tournament
in the history of quick African chess
$15,000 on the line with a grin
is a five grand they're going home with
in this tournament presented by Kasparov
chess Foundation Africa KCF francophone
Vivendi and the Ivorian Chess Federation
what an event okay but before we get to
our live round round number nine which
we are ten minutes away from starting
Robert let's take a look at what we have
been looking at the game of the event
not just the round but the event from
round number eight it was okay I'll do
the first name you do the last name okay
so was right it's fee Rakow tomorrow
yeah so you get you always get the easy
part alright good team all right I can
do this all the Dabu adieu events do you
know what people in the South say when
they get married no I do all right let's
take a look at your applause video game
Madagascar versus Nigeria in round
number eight now we'll go through the
whole game cuz this game was quite
notable wasn't it Robert yeah it's a
typical attacking game in the Sicilian
and since we have a few minutes before
the round gets started I think it's
worth it just to start from the very
beginning because we're gonna get to a
problem like position and pretty much
the middle game the stage of the game so
let's see efore c5 Knight f3 d6 CD 494
Knight f6 Knight c3 Bishop d7 the first
kind of a strange move especially since
we're so used to seeing the knight or
being played all the time but we'll see
that game quickly transposed it into
Asia Bennigan's type pawn structure
typical in the night off as well
a pawn structure popularized by Garry
Kasparov himself usually when we see the
night off
we associate it with the pawn structure
d 6 e 5 but the shiva Negin pawn
structure is characterized by what has
become known as the small centre
sicilian so these are pawns on d6 and e
6 now black is hopefully simply to
contain
White's attack in the center and the
queenside long enough to develop his own
queenside maybe get a rook to c8 and
target the Achilles heel the whites
position in the Sicilian you know what
that is
tell me it is this knight on c3 now
anybody that's played with white or with
black in the Sicilian has encountered at
one point or another games were black
sacrifices the exchange on c3 completely
shattering White's pawns on the Queen
side and maybe even picking up this
efore pawn so this is I would say the
main problem in White's position and
usually just as a general principle you
know I like those you don't want to be
putting your Knights in front of your
own pawns what you want is your pawn to
be in front of your knight
so this pawn serves as a sort of
bodyguard for the name and in the
Sicilian sometimes we actually do
encounter this pawn structure which is
called the Meraki bind on structure so
let's see what happened in the game
castles Bishop e7 f4 Knight c6 Knight B
393 an important move because if white
ignores this arrangement of pieces
knight on c6 Bishop on d7 it's gonna
allow black to relieve his position
quite a bit by trading off this Knight
and then replacing it with a bishop on
c6 and we see that black is starting to
create some pressure here against efore
so general rule of thumb once black
plays Knight c6 Bishop d7 we want to
avoid this trade so we go Knight b3 and
now this Bishop and Knight arrangement
seems a little bit clumsy especially
because if this knight on f6 ever gets
attacked with g4 g5 as we'll see the
knight is not going to have its normal
retreat to d7 so sort of it gonna be a
domino effect
Bishop f3 rook c8 rook f2
Queen c7 a3 castles and white took some
precautionary measures here on the Queen
side with a3 and rook app to sort of
anticipating that the C file might whoa
where's my arrow going might be a
problem right because if black can play
d4 and expose the C coupon that could
prove to be a juicy target so rook d2
rook d8 Queen e1 bishop eh rook d1 rook
b8 black noticing that this knight on f6
might need a little bit of room in the
future so clearing the d7 square and
also clearing the D file for the rook
again we see the bishops being moved out
of the way of the rest of the pieces a
little theme here yeah so now g4 this is
what I was talking about this is White's
main idea in this Bishop e2 variation
against the night or Chevette again pawn
structure to finish your development and
then start going g4 g5 attack this
Knight if the bishops on d7 even better
but if it's not you should still go for
it
so rook G 296 King H 194 Bishop c1 and
again once we bring the rook to the
center the bishop can always drop back
to its initial Square from where it's
going to be eyeing the Kings side but
also helping us hold down the fort
on the other side of the board b4 takes
Knight takes Knight d4 knight c6 be 394
rook d4 Knight a4 g5
rook c8 Bishop b2 Bishop c6 f5 so white
is going for an all-out attack this
night on a5 is I think probably the main
problem that black has because usually
black wants to have his night on d7
whenever white plays f5 so that he can
follow up with 95 and land the knight on
the outpost so ef5 95 very nice
in-between move Bishop takes d5 rook
takes d5 now the knight on a5 is hanging
F takes e4 I think black thought that if
he played knight c6 now after a takes f5
what would get his pawn back with some
very good attacking prospects that even
here I think this is what black should
have gone for maybe after Bishop f8
followed by 95 black can sacrifice a
pawn in order to get some pieces off the
board especially this Bishop on b2 it
looks like an absolute monster but
instead black figured well I can throw
in this in-between move F takes me for
that way if you take on a5 I'll just
take on f3 and always good but after
Bishop takes knight c6 black was in for
a very unpleasant surprise now in chess
we have two big areas right tactics and
strategy I mean if you have to split
chest down the middle those are the two
fuels that you need to study in order to
improve and in order to improve those
fields you need to become familiar with
patterns you have tactical patterns and
strategic patterns now what we're about
to see is one of the most sophisticated
and also one of the most dangerous
tactical patterns around because it has
to do with King safety and it is the
double Bishop sacrifice my goodness yeah
so Bishop takes h7 all right I got to
get myself credit saw that move first
well know if you saw it you have to say
it in order to take credit I'm just
trying to figure out a way to justify it
yeah
after Bishop takes h7 King takes Queen
h4 King g8 and now do you know why I
call it a double bishop sacrifice I feel
like that bishop on b2 might be going
away soon
absolutely Bishop takes g7 so this is
gonna completely strip the black king of
the poems that are supposed to be
defending it so it's one of those rare
cases where the two pawns are worth more
than the two bishops
because of King safety remember King
safety is the most important theme in
chests before you start thinking about
the bishop pair or pawn structure you
got to be aware of what's going on with
your King Nigel short once I hope
jokingly said making a good point I
don't know why people care so much about
pawn structures when checkmate ends the
game so I think Nigel short would be
very happy with this game because now
after g6 the G file opens up and look at
this King all of black's pieces are on
the Queen side this King is getting
clobbered after Bishop f6 g7 and there
is just no way of preventing Queen h8
checkmate so black resigned a great
effort light feet and this would be main
one no matter what right there's no way
I'm even extend this no I mean I don't I
don't see any checks and if Bishop takes
g7 I'll just go Queen takes g7 is
checkmate so made on the next move well
absolutely yeah congratulations to fever
coat Omaha Rho from Madagascar this
junior champion or that he's the number
two junior in Africa right now he is 2
for 2 on the day he's added 4 points to
his tally just today and also of course
bossom Amin has as well those are the
only two perfect players going into this
final round 9 but before we get to round
9 which is beginning just about now on
chess 24 calm we got to give some
shoutouts first of all join the
conversation online with hashtag Africa
chess
the Twitter Facebook whatever get the
word out there this is a big deal this
event is a big deal also a Babatunde
ogen seeker would like us to know that
his website he's a CEO of africa chess
media africa chest Mediacom is launching
a YouTube channel and after today they
will have the Skype interviews that
we've had on the show with each of the
players at the end of the day so that's
gonna be really cool be sure be sure to
subscribe
not only the st. Louis Chess Club
YouTube channel but of course Africa
chess media and visit them online at
Africa just Mediacom ok so we are just
about ready to get underway with round
number 9 the final chance to score 2
points in any single game
let's take a look at the matchups for
round number 9 in round number 9 we will
have the Nigerian Ola Dabu adieu taking
on slim Volodya and slim of course is
not having very good tournament but
maybe maybe things will change in the
Blitz as well vocalist l ed nani taking
on the rico tomorrow let's see if he can
make it free for three Arthur said Guan
Yi taking on art Andrew K on day South
Africa's Kenny Solomon taking on how
goosh and that is how it says it says
Arthur Caio later for his name is Andrew
right I think so
I've been calling him Andrew this whole
time I hope that's okay wait I said hey
no no we're good we're good yeah and
then of course David Silva taking on
awesome Amin okay so let's dive right in
and go around the horn and take a look
at the games I understand that they have
just gotten underway so let's see what
programs are being played here Robert so
let's pull up the first game here
between Ola damu and I do and slim milf
odious so we have four moves and a
fairly typical symmetrical English so
it's really gonna depend on what kind of
pawn structure white and black choose
next this is kind of a critical juncture
in the opening because let's say why it
plays the normal move Knight f3 Black
has a lot of options here I mean he can
go for the e6 set up normally called the
Bobby Fischer system one that he
popularized you actually want a very
nice game against Tigran Petrosian or
black can also choose what's known as
the bahtman ik system with the pawn to
e5 so we all have to stay tuned and see
what pawn structure black chooses to
adopt there let's move on to the game
Ella nany against Rojo tomorrow how do
you wait how do you print Rocco I would
say ro rocoto Mahara I would say let's
go to Mike okay you just have to say it
a few times in the the highest-rated
international master in Morocco vocalist
L at Nani taking on our junior the
junior of the day you know our player of
the day the the game right I mean a very
inspired day for Rocco to Omaha ro did I
get it right this time
I was pretty good right look I don't
know if I'm right yeah you're right I
mean I corrected you last time on
kaduche and then and I was right I mean
gave you the the right or wrong well I
you know that would be very strong way
of putting it I mean I had a different
interpretation you could say so here we
have a London system the ever-so-popular
London system where the white just
played a four you know normally for the
London system to work for you you need
to make sure this Bishop on the floor
doesn't get trained it off white usually
does this by playing the move h3 so that
this Bishop can always find safe haven
on h2 so since I'm seeing this pawn on
h2 still I'm always looking at moves
like Knight h5 or Knight d5 trying to
chase this Bishop away in the hopes that
I can trade it off
the typical way of doing this is 9h five
of course it's Bishop g3 would just take
that fish up and we're very happy but
here maybe Y can go Bishop g5 although
even here after h6 Bishop h4 g5 Bishop
g3 I am not too worried about weakening
my king side as long as I can get this
bishop I think this might be an
interesting approach for black just
trying to take advantage of this the
absence of the h3 move in fact before
playing a four I would have played h3
almost automatically now maybe against
Knight age five I can try something like
Bishop e5 but even here I could go
something like f6 although is this gonna
be a problem with this night on h5
because maybe after Bishop takes the
eight rook takes I could run into
someone pleasantness with g4 in it I put
my knight on the rim and cut away any
kind of escape route through f6 or g7 so
good night yeah good night for the night
so maybe Bishop e5 is a bit of an issue
therefore it could just make this very
calm but sneaky move d6 and hoping white
is going to think oh he just wants to go
97 so I'll develop my knight and now I
can go Knight age 5 and you don't have
Bishop e5 anymore so of course after d6
y can just go h3 and I think the game's
gonna continue let's see what's going on
in this game segwang against Kye owned a
yes okay so they're in Andrew so this
looks like it was a perk defense and you
say it like perk it spurts right thought
it was purse it spurts but that's if you
pronounce it correctly
in America we just don't do that there's
a book actually called perk alert and
it's meant to be pronounced incorrectly
so the title works right exactly so you
know there's an art to pronouncing names
incorrectly but it is pertz it is a nice
a perk let's see if let's see what's
going on with the perk alert
now when you can't cut out your Bishop
you usually don't want it to get traded
off right because that's going to create
some weaknesses along that square
complex but if you haven't castled yet
that might not be such a big deal so
here I think that black is still in good
shape because in fact what black is
going to try to do is play something
like e 5 maybe play Bishop e6 or
although I've also seen this Bishop get
developed with B 5 and Bishop d7 so if
we can play something like e 5 97 b5
Bishop d7 and Castle queenside this King
is gonna be much safer than if it had
say capsule on the kingside where this
Queen is already making itself felt and
we don't usually have to be afraid of
stuff like Queen g7 let's say if black
goes b5 we might because then we just
get forked right we can't defend both
the knight and the rook so we can
prepare this move a little bit maybe
with 97 and let's say if white castles
then we can go a 5 and now Queen g7 is
no big deal because we just go rook f8
and everything is under control so we
can just prepare b5 Bishop d7 Castle
queenside so this game still seems like
things are under control
now let's see what we have in the game
Solomon hadoo Sh huh interesting
now this is the grand master game of the
round - oh that's right don't okay so
one so we should see some sparks flying
here hopefully yeah alright now this
looked like it might have been a King's
Indian
we'll see in a moment the the opening
but I'm wondering how did this and I get
to the outpost so quickly on the face of
it this should be a good position for
black because if you don't take the
knight on d4 I have a knight on the
outpost which is nice but if you do take
this knight on d4 well it's a it's black
smooth but let's say black makes some
move like Bishop d6 if we do take this
knight on d4 after a takes d4 you've
done something that you're not supposed
to do which is when you have an outpost
don't allow your opponent to make a
trade that will transform your outpost
into simply a square that's occupied by
a pawn however here we transform one
advantage for another we lose the
outpost that we gained a passed pawn in
the center and this is going to be a
protected passed pawn - once we play c5
so that is an important long-term
advantage so given that white is facing
an unpleasant enemy knight in the center
for an unpleasant enemy passed pawn in
the center I'm thinking black is doing
pretty well here because even after
Knight takes pawn takes let's say you go
Bishop d2 you've protected that I mean
you've blockaded the past pawn but the
bishop is not known as a particularly
good block ager on the other hand though
this little underwhelming isn't it yeah
I mean usually you want a knight
blocking the pawn because the night even
though it's doing this job of blocking
would also fulfill some offensive
capacities because if you ever go c5
this knight on d3 could put pressure on
the c5 pawn whereas this Bishop is
solely defensive it can only just
prevent you from pushing your pawn
forward and maybe if I can do something
like at 45 I could activate it but
that's not gonna be so easy
so my first impression is that black is
doing pretty well here let's see this is
the last game right something round yes
David Silva / fine Luanda Angola taking
on our leader Grandmaster ba salami
okay so very complicated position and an
aggressive setup chosen by white I mean
look at these pawns on h4 and g5 on the
face of it white seems to be doing
pretty well on the kingside I mean this
night on h7 is gonna take a while to get
back into the game with Knight f8 96
probably but also we have some stuff
going on on the Queen side in here I
think is where black is going to make
his advantage felt because well it's
blacks move and if we take on a4 after B
takes a 4 I mean look at these isolated
pawns here that is not a good pawn
structure for white moreover it would
seem like blacks bishops are not on
outposts per se because we can always
kick the bishop on g4 out with f3 or
keep the bishop on e5 out with f4 but in
both of those cases it's going to
require us to weaken our king side
position so again King safety might
become an issue but I'm very concerned
about the Queen side it's basically
gonna burden white in the sense that
white is gonna have to think okay I need
to give checkmate otherwise I'm just
strategically busted because every
endgame is gonna be bad we see that
black has only to pawn islands White has
one two three but within those three
islands he has two isolated pawns so
that is not where you want to be I mean
at any moment black could play a move
like Queen a5 and start chasing after
this a pawn also simple chessani when
you have a better posture you have time
on your side so you can also consider
maneuvers like tonight f8 96 the only
problem in blacks position is this
Knight on HS Evan that's out of the game
so things are looking pretty good for
black I think all right all right so
we've taken a look at all of the games
so far nothing too earth-shattering yet
well we actually have a ton of moves
that have occurred in the I do Bell ho
dia game okay go back to yeah we're
number one all right so we were talking
here about what to do as black after
Knight f3 but in fact white beat us to
it and played a slightly on Orthodox
moon III with the idea of developing the
knight via e 2 instead of f3 so that we
don't block our Bishop and look at this
move Bishop takes c3 a very nimzowitsch
like move giving up the bishop in order
to damage our opponent's pawn structure
so remember whenever you give up the
bishop you can't just think that you're
getting an even trade if you just remove
a bishop and a knight from the board and
the bishop is worth a little bit more
than the night so we need something else
to make it worth our while
and usually that something else is going
to be creating some kind of a pawn
weakness in our opponent's position so
in this case we are creating doubled
pawns and white took with the D pawn my
friends why do you take with a deep-ando
that's a good question I mean my first
impulse would be to bring the pawn
closer to the center although this might
lead eventually to a kind of NIMS oh hi
Pat position say if you go d4 I can go
bishop B 7 and later d6 rook c8
985 something like that and start
putting pressure on c4 however what
shouldn't go d4 unlike in the
nimzo-indian our pawn is still on d2 and
we can just play the pawn to d3 to make
sure that c4 is never weak and then
we'll go see for 92 I happen to think
that the bishops should be worth
something here
if the pawns on d4 maybe the situation
would be different well the situation
would definitely be different because c4
would always be weak but here White's
pawn structure it even though it has
doubled pawns looks quite sturdy because
all the pawns are protecting each other
and the only theoretically weak bond is
c3 but it's so close to all the whites
pieces that it's very easy to defend
lose like 92 Queen c2 if I really have
to so I was a little bit surprised with
D takes c3 as well the idea is that you
open up the D file so that you can maybe
put some pressure along here maybe by
playing efore 92 Knight f4 and Knight d5
this is the famous Sentinel that
nimzowitsch spoke of he said we would
really like this pawn structure to
evolve into a backward pawn for black
but of course black is never gonna play
a six or a five willingly so how are we
gonna provoke him to do this to weaken
his own position well there's a way of
doing this actually for example it's
blacks move let's say I'll make a couple
of random moves just to show you my idea
Bishop Issei all the show p6 is actually
not going to show you my idea
so let's say I go clean that up the
board yeah so castles let's go b6 Knight
f4 Bishop d7 it's go rook e1 castles h3
these are not the best moves but
nimzowitsch said bring your knight to
the central square as sort of a fishing
pole this is the bait that way your
opponent will get tempted to chase it
off and then there's just no problem you
retreat but you've created the backward
pawn
so it's a very provocative strategy in
order to lure your opponent into making
a weakness that you'd normally wouldn't
even think of what if that what if the
opponent doesn't fall for it I mean then
you've just made several moves for for
nothing is there payoff in that regard
well I mean this night doesn't look too
shabby on d5 right if you want to leave
it there fine by me I can live with that
I mean I can just continue with my
normal development maybe Bishop h6 Queen
d2 rook a d1 and pile up the pressure on
d6 I think eventually you'll have to
break and play me six get this night out
so let's see what happened I think
that's basically the idea after DK
exceed so black goes 'if I've creating
the backward pull right away but all of
a sudden it's not so easy to really use
this outpost either because we've taken
the f4 square away from white so castles
h5 Queen d3h formed rook d1 King e7 what
is this wow so it looks like black is
going for King side attack but you would
think that this Queen should be not
blocked by the king but I guess he wants
to keep a 7 protected and there's just
no way of defending it otherwise right I
mean you don't have Knight yeat or
anything so maybe king e7 is the only
move yeah
Wow okay so ii for hg f g it's funny in
this game we are breaking some general
principles that tell us we should always
recapture with our pawns towards the
center and here white did exactly the
opposite on two occasions first when he
played d takes c3 and now by playing F
takes G 3 but in both cases he does have
a specific goal in mind these are called
the exceptions to the rule he wants to
use the open D file to put pressure on
d6 and maybe the open F file to put
pressure on f7 and target this King on
ISA so after Bishop g4 Bishop e3 Queen B
7 B 4 B 6 I'm guessing it would be too
risky to capture this pawn because after
Knight takes this clean to come to b3
and later we can finally ha wait a
minute I can't do this because Knight is
hanging so let me go Queen d2 first and
now after you move the knight I mean I
could move the rook but I'm wondering if
I can sack the exchange
maybe this is too optimistic right
because after takes 95 you can probably
just hide away with your King right King
f8 rook takes do you why I don't see an
immediate threat for white so this isn't
working so I could just go rook F 1
preparing Knight c3 it looks like white
has some decent compensation so
black said I'll have none of this went
be six and that's where we're at so what
is going on how do we evaluate this
position I mean at first glance I would
think that White's just better right
because we're not down any material we
have two files for our rooks and a
fairly decent chance that the position
will open up because we'll go roof D to
work a t1 or we can even swing over to
the F file and we have some tension here
sure black is in no hurry to place he
takes before but this should be a lot
easier to play with white than with
black I don't know what to make of slim
Velho Diaz performance thus far in this
event he's over eight fifty five years
old you know all of the games so far
have been played in rapid time control
that me this guy is he's Africa's first
Grandmaster you know he represents
Tunisia he lives in Paris do you I mean
this has got to be amongst one of his
most underwhelming performances ever I
what what would be going through your
mind if you were oh and eight in this
event well let me tell you one thing if
you've made it to GM you are not a
stranger to pain so you know bad
tournaments happened to everyone and
once you've been a chess professional
for a while you you learn to deal with
this and to pretty much shake it off
because at the end of the day people
don't really remember the bad
tournaments they remember the good ones
so for every bad tournament I mean for
every good tournament there's probably
like five or ten bad ones but
fortunately for us our mind works in a
way that just blocks those out yeah and
keeps the good ones to remember yeah you
got to remember that yeah absolutely so
let's go back to this game the Elat Nani
rocoto mahara game Rocco
because something similar to what we
were talking about happen right black
did go for Knight h5 but he didn't go d6
which seemed tempting to me just to take
control of this he 5 square now
after a 5 c4 c4 a move that I'm not so
sure what to make of it if it's a good
move or a bad move see when I do when I
am trying to figure out whether a good
move is back
whether good movies bad know whether a
move is good or bad is first run it
through the general principle like
without calculating any variations does
this move look good or bad see for the
plus side is it gains space and space is
usually a good thing but on the negative
side it gives up the central tension
which is generally a bad thing now
what's worth more space or central
tension well if there are no other
factors involved I tend to favor the
central tension however here c4 does
target and a potential outpost on b3 so
for example black and try to prepare it
move like knight c6 Knight 85 and
eventually use the B 3 square but
something doesn't quite convince me
about this because I think like after
Knight d2 lot might have a hard time
getting there so the game went a takes
b6 Queen takes Knight bTW - so we see
that aside from the outpost on v3 we
also have a backward pawn on b2 so all
of a sudden maybe this is an exception
to the rule because it's not just space
for central tension we also have an
outpost and a backward pawn to consider
and those are important factors so I
think black is doing ok here after 97
be three smart choice by white trying to
get rid of this weakness but after C
takes b3 Queen takes b3 black played
nine h5 but it's worth pointing out that
you got rid of the backward punt on b2
but now you still have a backward pawn
on c3 so in order to really solve your
problems you're gonna have to go c4
Knight h5 Bishop g5 again it would be a
huge huge accomplishment for black to
chop off this dark square Bishop because
now it can actually fight for the open B
file which we can't do when there's a
bishop on that floor so Bishop g5 f6
Bishop h4 g5 and this is where we're at
in the game or actually I think it went
a couple more moves let me just update
this board so Bishop g3 Knight takes age
things hmm alright so the blacks feeling
pretty good about this right yeah I mean
I would feel pretty good I am Anna get
rid of this dark square bishop which is
gonna be a big relief for black the only
thing maybe at least a little bit work a
little bit of work is how we're gonna
get this bishop involved but I suppose
we could play something like rook fc8 c6
and Bishop f8
if we have enough time white should
probably think of doing something like
c4 very soon just to get rid of this
backward pawn like we said black is very
happy if something like this happens
right because now c4 is not going to be
so easy to achieve I mean all of our
pieces are pointing at c4 maybe after
rook FC 1 you will get c4 anyway I don't
know maybe like e6000 a say on the next
spoon on the plus side white got rid of
all his pawn weaknesses he has no more
backward pawns but black has the bishop
pair and this is an isolated pawn on a 7
but it's also an outside passer and in
an endgame the outside passer should not
be underestimated
so overall I think the game should be
balanced but maybe a little bit of
danger for white due to the bishop pair
on the outside passer let's see what we
have going on the sequani game so after
f3 black did go Knight bt7
Castle queenside b5 king b1 Knight b6
interesting
night II - and a similar concept going
on here from what we've seen in the
Sicilian where we said that the night
feels a little bit uncomfortable in
front of its own pond so white plays
this very unorthodox move right Knight
to e2 when you still have your king site
to develop but I like this move a lot
it's a pragmatic thinking you know you
don't want to be dogmatic and say oh
development you know before anything
else you've got to deal with the
immediate problems so what white is
intending to do is to put the night on
c1 which is going to protect your king
especially the a2 square it's going to
be out of the way so that can't be
targeted with b4 and once the knight
gets to see one you can play Bishop d3
or Knight h3 Knight g5 or h4 g4 so I
like this move Knight c4 Knight c1 g5
wow what a move
so if Queen takes g5 this is what
happened I want to see what blacks idea
is Robert I yep don't mean to interrupt
but possum Ameen has cleared it three
for three on the day he has defeated
with the black pieces David Silva oh wow
let's go and take a look at that so this
game let's see what happened after
before we transpose into a fianchetto
variation of the King's Indian and we
had seen that whites situation on the
Queen side was a little bit delicate at
least for my tastes
but I wanted to see how we actually got
there so here we go
this g4 move maybe created a target as
opposed to an attack now Knight h7h for
Bishop g4 with t2 Bishop e5 9a for
Knight takes so this is where we had
left off and I was thinking that Knight
takes a four completely shattering
whites Queen side pawn structure looked
promising so there we go Knight f8 so
when you have a better posture you have
time you have time to identify what is a
potential problem or an actual problem
in your position and fix it so this is
not an H 7 wasn't doing anything
now it gets brought back into the game
King H 1 Queen B 4 so already we see our
first serious threat of the game Queen
takes a form so white plays rook in a
197 and look at this the night that was
doing nothing on h7 in a couple of moves
has found a nice square and it's heading
towards the outpost so if this a knight
gets to c5 I think White's position
might simply collapse so Bishop f1
Knight c5 Bishop c3 oh wow what a what a
shot so after Bishop c3 White was
probably counting on the move Queen b6
which I'm sure is still a good position
for black but at least there's no
immediate threat on the a4 pawn instead
black plays Bishop f3 and the point is
if you go Knight takes f3 I go Queen
takes f3 and I'm forking your rook and
your knight
and if you take on c3 Bishop takes now
I'm at least gonna win the exchange but
also later I'm gonna pick up some pots
so we can't take on f3 king h2 the queen
is still being threatened and Bishop
takes e4 Oh another in-between moon
leaving the Queen on pre-owned before
so if Bishop takes b4 this is what
happened Bishop takes c2 and now you
can't play rook take c2 because a bishop
takes d4 and you're just down upon and
you still have weaknesses and if Knight
takes c2 Bishop takes a one Knight takes
a one you might think oh I have two
minor pieces for a rope that's usually a
good deal but here after rook takes a
four you might have Bishop takes c5 so
I'm not really threatening both pieces
but maybe rook e1 and I don't think you
can really protect both your Bishop and
your night at the same time so so very
inspired play by bossom needs today
Bishop takes c5 d take c5 Knight takes
c2 Bishop takes Knight takes rook e1 and
here is where white resigned
right you're just going to lose one of
your minor pieces you're gonna be down
in exchange you're gonna be down a
couple pawns it's game over great game
by black and if you look at ba so Amin
he has been undefeated in this entire
rapid portion of the tournament out of a
possible 18 points he has an amazing 15
points and after this victory he has a
what I would call beginning to be a
significant lead yeah and also aside
from the actual points themselves
you can feel how his level is picking up
as a turn
it goes on you know he started off maybe
it was a little bit cold and now he's
warmed up and this is by far his best
game of the tournament I mean it was a
total blowout some very sharp tactics
and accurate play by him I think that
you know he's the guy to watch now not
just because he's the highest rated
player but his games have been steadily
improving as the tournament has
progressed so I absolutely agree let's
see all right we still have four games
going on in this final rapid game rapid
round nine yeah I see you pulling up
Kenny Solomon versus Mohammed huh douche
I got have a quick correction they'll
have to correct what I said earlier
slim Bell whole yet was not Africa's
first grandmaster that is actually
Grandmaster slim Boise's from Algeria
not in this tournament thank you to
Graham Jorgensen for that correction all
right now let's all a slim though yeah
still a slim right it's not a common
name in Africa I don't know we're have
but it seems to be a good omen if you
want to become a GM yeah so let's see
what we have here Solomon against a
douche the position has changed
considerably now there are two kinds of
changes in a chess game that are going
to have a long-term impact on the game
and those are changes in the pawn
structure or piece traits because there
are the only kind of decisions that we
can't undo in chess mean if like we
looked at the Boston amine game
previously and we saw he had this night
on h7 it was misplaced and in a couple
of moves he went Knight f8 97 95 and
that night was amazing so misplaced
pieces is not something that's going to
have a long-term impact on the game
however a bad pawn structure is a bad
piece trade is because you can't move
your pawns backward you can't relocate
them like you could with a piece or
piece trades you can't unless you're
playing bughouse you can't just throw
the piece back in the board so
in this game we've seen a significant
change in the pawn structure because
black had an outpost on d4 because he
had a pawn on e5 and that pawn has now
disappeared
so technically d4 is no longer an
outpost but in order to achieve this
white had to play f4 and trade off that
pawn and in so doing created an isolated
pawn on e4 so we see that you know chess
is a very dynamic game you know one
thing can transform into another and
learning how to transform these
advantages for example from having an
outpost to exploiting an isolated pawn
by your opponent is the hallmark of good
chess players usually GM's so even
though the position has changed I think
black retains a nice advantage because
we lost the outpost on d4 that we may
gain an outpost on e5 and I'm thinking a
move may be like clean e5 Bishop d6
could lead to an interesting King side
attack or simply use e5 as a pivot point
or maybe use the default but also I'm a
little bit puzzled by how white achieved
an exchange because materials not even
so I would like to go back a couple of
moves and see how we got here
because after f4 takes Bishop g4 rook d2
96 there should be six okay so after
Bishop d6 black gave up the exchange and
now it's gonna use d4 d5 I I understand
them so rook F 294 Queen d2 Bishop e6
and that's how we got here alright so I
would say that black has tremendous
compensation for the exchange we have
the bishop pair we have some strong
squares like d4 outpost like a five the
open file to put pressure on because
maybe we can pin this bishop that would
be very optimistic about blacks position
let's see what else we have going on
here
it looks like Arthur said Wanya has a
big advantage over Andrew coyote if we
wanted to take a look at that one
absolutely so we had seen black
sacrificed upon my playing g5 and after
Queen takes rook g8 Queen up for 9 h5
Queen h6 Knight f6 so something has gone
wrong here for black because he's trying
to repeat moves and usually when you
sacrifice a pawn you you want to thrust
your pieces forward and get an attack
going but here if you have to repeat
moves and especially if White's not
forced to repeat moves that's a bad sign
so after clean of 4/9 h5 Queen h4 and 93
I'm interesting now I'm wondering why
did white go back to a 4 here what is so
serious that requires the attention of
the Queen for example
why can't I play something like oh this
might be interesting so for example if I
go night h3 then you might play rook g6
and if Queen ax 4 mm I see now that my
queen is no longer tending to the night
you can destroy my King sight pawn
structure you might get some
compensation here and if I go Queen h4
you might go 93 again so let's see what
happened after Queen at 4 9 h5 Queen h4
93 Knight B 3 nice in-between move
because if we go rook e1 I guess can
black get his paws back by going no you
can't take on if wanna take on g2
because h5 is thing but I mean your
knight is under attack I can't deflect
your queen so let this work on e1 is
hanging so I think I have to take and
now I mean I have to drop back with the
night so what happens if I just go Queen
up to
I don't know
isn't weight just up upon ya so this
looks like a good position for white but
okay white through in the move Knight be
three and after Queen before is White's
move now the first move that comes to my
mind is c3 just consolidating or pawn
center a little bit driving the black
Queen to a passive square so I think you
have to go
Queen a4 and now I can do rook e1 and
this should lead to a very similar
position takes takes Knight f6 and maybe
just clean f2 also maybe if I'm feeling
very ambitious I might be able to
capture on h5 and your knight on f1
looks trapped I don't see a good way out
here yeah I mean this this looks even
better so blacks in trouble here I don't
like this at all yeah this is looking
good for Uganda's art there sejuani who
right now is around the middle of the
pack trying to still break through I
mean he's standing with five out of
possible 16 right now if he wins that
game he'll be at 7 anything can happen
in blitz but he's still trying this
thing so let's go back to this game
between Ella Donnie and Rocco tomorrow
is that right
and he stayed a little bit different
every time and that's look Rocco Toma
Hawk covering the spectrum one of these
times no but I'm saying it differently
closer to the truth each time or just I
don't know what the truth is ok but
because I think we're gonna talk to him
later in the show okay so here we go
after H takes g3 instead of the Moog FC
8 targeting the backward pawn on c3
black played rook FBA I guess he
understood that you can't really stop c4
so it doesn't make sense to put pressure
on a weakness that's not going to be a
weakness vers for very long
Queen a to e6 so here we go we're trying
to activate the bishop through f8 now we
shouldn't try to activate the bishop
with f5 which might seem like the most
obvious path because every time we move
upon we create a weakness and here if we
want to move the F pawn we would have to
move the Jeep on and even if we managed
to move the F pawn we weaken the e5
square even if it wasn't weak this
Bishop would just be biting into White's
punching so I like e6000 under control
Knight b3 Queen d6 night a5 so white
also playing some interesting moves
because this night on a5 it's on the rim
and this is generally a bad thing
but even though a5 is not technically an
outpost at the very least it's a square
that black cannot control with a pawn
so if black can't chase the night away
with a pawn the night feels generally
comfortable I mean Knights are afraid of
pawns like elephants are afraid of mice
are elephants afraid of mice of course
they they like can crawl up the nose
what's the nose call it an elephant
trunk no the trunk yeah I was thinking
of nostril yes
yeah so they panic I mean haven't you
ever seen cartoons you learned something
new every day
okay so after Knight a5
Knight b6 Knight d2 Bishop f8 rook f b1
Queen c7 and White's playing with fire
because he should have well he was able
to make this trade Knight takes b7 for a
couple of moves and that would have
deprived black of the bishop pair
probably his main asset in this position
so if we delay this trade too long and
allow black to simply go bishop c8 and
tuck this bishop away and that's gonna
make it very hard to trade so after rook
c1 Queen d7 rook a b1 Bishop c6 now
finally Knight takes c6 now I would have
I don't know I want to play Bishop c8 so
bad why can't I play Bishop c8 here is
this a terrible mistake I mean you have
to go c4 and now if I take what is the
problem I mean if you go Knight takes e4
Knight takes c4
maybe Bishop takes and you have some
pressure against my backward fun so the
tables have turned
I thought I was gonna put pressure on
your backwards pawns when you had him on
B 2 and C 3 and it turns out I'm the one
left holding the backward pawn on e6 so
maybe we can't really keep our strategic
advantage because of c4 opening up the
position it's weird right we have the
bishop pair and we don't want the
position to open up I guess it just
exposes our weakness so an interesting
exception to the rule here after Queen
d7 route b1 bishop c6 Knight takes Queen
takes and I gotta say now that the
bishop pair is off the board I like
White's position quite a bit I mean all
we have to do is get rid of our weak c3
pawn with c4 and for example after D
takes whoa I was gonna go Knight takes
but I was thinking maybe there's some
bishop have three stuff going on here
you can just go 95 probably
and I could go Knight takes e4 but are
there some tactics here with evil I
don't know now I think I can just go
night before I was hoping that black had
to retreat with the knight to a passive
square so that I could go he five and
after Knight d5 ef6 and now I've
completely shattered your king signs and
left you with tons of pawn weaknesses
but yeah if I had to make an obvious ID
for prevents that yeah so instead of
going to be six oops
what lion will be W after E for Knight
be four right yeah yeah so this hits the
Queen this might make it a little bit
harder so e for premature perhaps so I
can probably just take on c4 and
consolidate my position and just take
advantage of my better pawn structure my
more active Bishop my presence on the
Queen side maybe I'm gonna go Knight a5
kind of reload my knight that I liked so
much on eighty-five before I can just
bring the other one there I think this
game is the tides returning here
I remember the last time we looked at it
I was optimistic about blacks position
but here it's all about white it looks
like as I'm doing a quick look at the
evaluations for all these games it looks
like the tides have turned and pretty
much in a lot of the games three of them
look pretty equal Kenny Solomon versus
Muhammad huh douche black is has the
edge there and it looks like they're in
the end games out okay so let's take a
look at that
six minutes to three minutes left and
remember these are gaming 25 with a
ten-second delay just a 10-second delay
it's all you have to work with so these
games are coming to the end so let's see
where we left off now we said this
you know there was an exchange sacrifice
and here we go Bishop e6 white played b5
rook a3 I guess trying to target this
knight on c3 that's kind of loose so
maybe we can try to go something like
Queen e5 Bishop b4 or maybe even Queen
before or queen c5 so it takes takes e5
Queen takes e5 and now White has to be
very very careful because this Bishop
can spring into action at any moment it
can come to g6 threatening h2 if you can
come to c5 trying to take advantage of
this diagonal maybe pinning the rook or
it can come to be for painting the night
so a lot of good options for this Bishop
Bishop takes g6 I guess this is what
White was counting on when he sacked the
pawn playing a 5 then after F takes G 6
we could simply take on f8 and get rid
of that really dangerous dark square
Bishop but now counter-attack rook takes
c3 you can't play Queen takes c3 goes 92
and there's a discovery on your queen so
that's not good
but now Bishop takes f7 check Bishop
takes rook takes and I'm threatening
threatening your Bishop on f8 and am i
threatening you work on c3 well no
there's a but we're still there for it
is trying to like presented and I was
like discover still there it's still
there okay yeah so 92 this rook on c3 is
taboo so we just have to deal with the
threat on our Bishop and that's what
black does Bishop g7 King h1
now we're threatening Queen takes c3 so
black simply has to move this work away
but two minor pieces are generally
stronger than a rook and I don't think
this is going to be an exception
although it should be pointed out that
the black king is slightly more exposed
than the white king so if there is hope
of salvation for white it's going to
revolve around targeting this king so
maybe white is gonna have to do
something like Queen a2 or get this
Queen a little bit closer to the King on
the G file if we get a queen to g6 for
example we would be threatening
checkmate already in one move but that's
not going to be easy so I'm thinking
it's gonna have to be an attack on the
king and it's gonna have to be along
light squares as well so maybe something
like Queen a2 trying to go to a eight or
maybe trying to go to be one and then g6
I think this is White's best shot so
let's see so you mean you're thinking
about this from from why it's
perspective it does this black have an
edge here at all I think black has a big
advantage here okay I think these two
minor pieces are much more dangerous
than the ruse in fact I think that if
black can muster up some kind of play
against g2 he his position could just
explode
maybe prepare something like well
Queenie for I can't yet because this
rook is hanging so I have to do
something about the rook I don't know if
I would want to go rook c2 because then
after Queen d3 I'm sort of helping white
get to the square that he wants to get
to which is g6 so as black I know that
the dark squares aren't a problem I have
a dark square Bishop I have pretty much
all my pieces on dark squares so I need
to start compensating the light squares
maybe I would go something like rook III
getting the rook out of the threat and
prepare something like Queenie for
seizing control of a very important
diagonal because if I put my Queen on e4
then I know my king is gonna be safe on
h7 too because there's gonna be no
checks and once the Queen's on e4 I can
prepare rookie to and target g2 I can
also start maneuvering with my knight I
can start pushing this C pawn as well
there are a lot more elements to be
happy about in Velox position than
whites so yeah I think a big advantage
for black here Mohammed a douche number
two seed in this tournament number four
player in all of Africa
this Algerian player if he wins today he
will be a significantly clear second to
bossom Amin I mean they're playing for
basically a handicap going into the
Blitz round how big is your handicap
going to be and he'll be just one point
behind I mean if he wins this game yeah
so I'd say we should stick to this game
because we're getting some moves
and even though hadoo she has the better
position he is down on the clock he has
less than one minute left and his
opponent has a substantial time
advantage he has four minutes so while
we can stay here if you'd like I gotta
say that mukhlis elad Nani and the
rocoto mahara have drawn their game so
that means that Rakow tomorrow will not
end the game well not in the day
perfectly like I'm being did but still
very good performant performance for him
a good day yeah so here we saw that
black did play rookie three and after
Queen a2 King aged seven so
white goes h3 and now I would seriously
consider playing a move like Queenie for
but maybe this would be terrible because
I blunder mate in like a couple moves
right rook takes g7 King takes Queen f7
check and is there there's got to be
checkmate here right rook f7 yeah Brooke
if sub King g6 and am I gonna go oh yeah
so this little thing yes yep that is a
nice pattern so white is making some
interesting moves sort of inviting me to
carry out my idea and blunder the game
in the process so I can't quite go
Queenie for yet I have to do something
to strengthen my situation on the King
side maybe something like 96 over
protecting the bishop may be preparing
Knight g5 or also preparing Queenie for
the important thing is that we've
noticed this Bishop on g7 could be
vulnerable so let's see
let's go back to the game oh my gosh
only five seconds left for hadoo SH Wow
so rook d1 and Queens came off the board
and the pawn structure changed I mean
this is crazy
let's see how that happened after King H
won Rookie 3 Queen a to King h7 h3 Queen
d5 instead of 96 and after takes takes
rook d7 I think that having traded the
Queens
White is gonna feel like his position
has been considerably relieved now rook
d1 and it's not easy to move this night
away right I mean if this Knight moves
we're just gonna take the pawn on d5 and
what should hold this quite easily hey
guys I gotta tell you while we're
analyzing here remember
chess 24 comm is where you can see these
games live if you want to if you want to
stay up to date on the latest position
chest 24 comm look for C IV rapid and
blitz so this actually happened in the
game instead of going to e to black play
Knight f5 white took on d5 and I think
that when you feel the game slipping
away like this it's time to call it a
day maybe take on d5 King g6 and just
buckle down and hold that draw which
black should have no problem doing so I
think this game is gonna fizzle out into
a draw sequani and Kai own day I think
is the next game of importance it looks
like black has a huge edge as there are
just seconds left on blacks clock so
what's going on in this game this was
the game where we saw Bishop takes c3 I
believe right or mine no this was the
perk game okay so white went from having
a big advantage to now being in huge
trouble this is quite a pickle here
black is up upon he also has active
pieces I mean that rook on c3 is hanging
but I think we could just go rook c5
and now after a four we need to see if
we can hold on to this pawn on e3 this
would be nice but otherwise we could
simply try it go for a counter-attack I
mean now if white tries to attack our
pawn on e3 we'll just take the pawn on
g2 and that should still be a good deal
because we'll be up upon at an end game
and after g4 maybe just h5 trying to
expose the weakness of the h3 point yeah
this this should be a nice advantage for
black so what happened here
so after Knight takes d5 like did play
rook c5 8 for Knight e4 rook e1 e2
playing for some tactics here I'm
guessing after rook takes e to black
wants to go rook takes b5 and after we
can't play a b5 because of Knight c3 of
course but now after rook takes we can
go rook takes King c2 we can play I
believe route before or maybe not
I thought perhaps this endgame was
winning but actually this ending is
gonna be losing for white because white
is gonna create an outside passer on
both wings both flanks and that should
win the game so you need to be a little
bit careful as Black Knight g3 securing
this powerful pawn on e 2 nights e3
rookie 5 king C to d5 king d3 qd6
knight takes eetu and d4 so
white managed to level the material and
get rid of this very powerful pawn on e2
but he's put himself in an awkward
situation by pinning his own itani - now
the question is what happens if we
simply defend our rook and prepare to
get our night out of here I think we can
try to trade everything and this end
game should black win if I go King
before I'm just always so afraid of the
outside passer
because if white can get these Kings
side pawns rolling my king is a not
going to be able to stop them so easily
and I'm also worried that in an endgame
if my King goes to the other side of the
board white might play b4 and unleash an
outside passer on the Queen side it
looks like to me that white would win
this race yeah it's it's not entirely
clear to me because we do have to pass
pawns here in the center that we can
support with our King so for example if
g4 king or efore I have a feeling this
should be good for black let's see
what's happening in the game oh yeah a
lot of whoa a lot of things have
happened look at this let's let's take a
look so after white took on e to d4 King
D - this did happen so we trade it but
he didn't go into the King and pawn
endgame instead he went rook g5 I mean
it makes sense right when you have a
little time you can't really I mean if
you gave me an hour I'm not sure it
would be able to figure it all out so in
five seconds it's a total order so now a
five
b3 I was thinking maybe rook a3 but okay
a six check takes takes a seven
and after E - it looks like we're going
to be entering a queen end game here
they come and this is gonna be a very
own plus these guys are blitzing out
moves really left and right yeah this is
just that in checking war with these
queens yeah well I think this war is
gonna be over very soon because black is
simply gonna go b2 b1 and the fact that
black still has a pawn on e5 is gonna
allow his king to find shelter without
too many inconveniences so real quick I
gotta say that Kenny Solomon and
Mohammed ha do the Grand Master game of
the round ended in a draw and I expected
so that's two games left let's stick
with this game again look at Black has a
great position but look at the times he
only has 14 seconds and white has over
two minutes right and normally whenever
you play what essentially has become a
blitz game when you have an increment
you can build up time there's no way you
can build up time you're just the lane
yeah yeah so that definitely doesn't
help the side with the few seconds left
right especially because I think most
players are used to the increment as
opposed to the delay you might get this
false sense of security like oh I have a
delay it's like increment and then you
realize oh I still have 10 seconds I'm
sure they stress that at the player
meeting before this thing yeah
absolutement in this event so white kept
checking and this King seems to be
finding shelter can white coat Queen
takes e5 I think that's what happened so
now after a b2 the question is am I
going to be able to Queen this pawn I
think so right after b2 if you start
giving checks
I can just start running away right
maybe King d1o but then you just go
queen f1 I'll have to repeat moves so
since Queen f1 is a problem maybe I can
go King e2 and if you go Queen f3 check
if I can go King e1 and if you go
between III I'm gonna use your own pawns
against you
I'm gonna go King f1 I'm going to tuck
my king away on the corner and use your
own pawns as shelter from the checks so
let's see what's happening in the game
oh here whoa what's going on
so he didn't play b2 I guess he played
Queen d3
what happened here after Queen takes e5
you might please see for Chuck after G
for King c2 Queen f5 Queen d3 Queen c5
yeah I would have pushed that pawn to b2
and taking advantage of the fact that
the pawns were still on g2 and h3 to
hide backing away now with the pawn on
g4 it seems like the White Queen can
always find a check
let's see green f4 and this is where the
game is so far yeah all of a sudden
maybe this isn't so easy I mean I would
like to take this pawn and start rolling
my Jeep on but if I did something
careless like King g5 king h6 you might
just mate in the end one move with a
queen g6 Oh Robert
yeah our fourth game to end this round
in a battle between
Oladipo adieu and slim Bell Jota slim
has earned his first spot on the
leaderboard all right as a pope well
full two points he defeated his opponent
with black in a game that came down to
less than 10 seconds for each player so
congratulations to slim bill already
slim on the board yes excellent so we
have our last game still Arthur say Guan
Yi and Andrew kiona Danny this game is
just crazy yeah I have to tell you
though from personal experience these
Queen end games are an absolute
nightmare I tend to draw them when I'm
winning and I tend to lose them when I'm
drawing does that make sense
so you mess up yeah all the time so I
know they're just hard on whichever side
you're on but here we see that white
might actually be putting up a pretty
strong resistance because he's somehow
managed to get rid of this h7 pawn and
in this position I don't see a good
place to put this King to shelter from
all the checks and fortunately for white
this King is fairly out of the way so
it's not going to be easy for black to
let's say cover a check and give
check at the same time forcing a queen
tree I mean Queen trade is basically
what black is hoping for so I think
black has gotten himself in some hot
water here it's not gonna be easy to win
this end game especially if you have 14
seconds right and they keep on ticking
yep I mean these times that we're
looking at right now they're they're
being relayed from quite a distance
they're mostly correct and if you see a
zero pop up on the screen for a moment
that doesn't necessarily mean that one
of the players has has flagged on time
you know but it come very close yeah so
here I'm I'm gonna predict a lot of
checks for a very long time and normally
you know if you're black and you have
little time you think I'll just give a
bunch of checks accumulate some time and
think but here that's it I mean that's
all the time you're getting you're gonna
get maybe a little breather what was it
five second or 10 second to the 10
second delay fees but it's not going to
radically change your time situation so
I'm feeling optimistic about white
holding this endgame
I can't believe I'm saying that because
White's position look reasonable going
into the endgame but that's how it goes
this is our last game going on this is
the last game going on right now I have
believed that will be talked after this
game ends will be using Skype to connect
with bossom Amin and the Rakata Maya
mehar oh all right talk about their
spectacular days and we'll Gary Kasparov
and a naturally Karpov be joining us to
analyze that endgame I think I heard a
rumor well we'll see maybe right you may
know something I don't know
well we'll see who's on the other end of
that I haven't heard that they're not
gonna be joining nice no so they'll take
hot chocolates please stay tuned so you
don't know you don't know right but
Kasparov chess Foundation Africa was one
of the big sponsors so there you go he's
coming
yeah bring it around home see how I did
that yeah yeah so I think that let's see
Queen b3 King e1 now it would be nice
for example if white plate Queen g3 they
go check and they you know we have to a
new trade Queen's it you're not very
happy but the funny thing is you're not
really threatening to go b1 so I can
actually get my King out of the way
maybe I can go King h5 preparing Queen
g3 and may be preparing h4 and little by
little hopefully I can
I don't think White's goal is to
actually Queen here but rather just
stick with the perpetual check let's see
what's going on here
this is not a good sign right if you
were hoping to shelter your king from
the checks and how your King is dancing
in the middle of the board or maybe I
don't know I think you should be able to
check this king for a very long time but
maybe what black is hoping to do is
bring the king to b5 that way if you
check me I can sort of block the check
and do a counter check and trade queens
so white needs to be a little bit
careful not to give a check along the
fifth-ranked which is worth his king's
gonna be so this is a good move Queen a4
King d5 Queen b3 King Yvonne I think
this is heading towards a draw
what's gonna happen here
queen bee five i mean this is the move
that would make sense to me
King f6 might threaten checkmate at some
point but I think you're just gonna get
checked these guys are already on move
112 when was the last captured oh it
wasn't that long ago okay it was like 13
yeah I mean this is not gonna be a fun
game to enter into your computer after
you're done with the wonders of digital
technology hopefully it's already in the
computer yeah you know I recently
discovered because I play tournaments
and I have this habit after I finish my
game I I go to my room and I enter the
game and sometimes it's these very long
games I'm like oh this this isn't fun
and then I realize I can just download
the PGN is there somebody else doing all
the work for me
yeah so that's nice so here how many
moves have gone by since their last
wander do you know can you look that up
it well with don't don't just count them
wait and be no way no way let's see so
here we see a move 73 I think g4 oh it
wasn't the last pawn move because there
was a capture on h7 as well and it be -
yeah the capture one was the capture
here move 79 so how many moves that we
need to make you're the math guy 129 and
we're at 114 who knows if they'll claim
it you know I mean well because you'd
have it on a dgt board right yeah but I
mean I think the players still have to
claim it to some extent right oh look
white one what well hold on hold on now
that might be updated we don't know for
sure that white one maybe he went on
time cuz black was very low yes that
might be the case but you would think
that he would just say draw right like
if you lose on time you say okay draw
try to trick them yeah like okay
well the dgt is registering that the
arbiters have called Arthur's suwanee
the winner of this game that would be a
heartbreaker but I want to believe that
it's a DGT slip-up yeah are you calling
here call someone so skype has this
funny way of deactivating the mute on my
computer I've never seen anything like
it
it goes it just bust right through that
I had muted it and it's like we're gonna
give you that everybody heard you yeah
so we're going to be contacting the
players shortly here we're going to
interview do we know yet yes we'll be
talking to fee Ricardo Ricardo maja row
and then we'll be talking to me so let
me pull up my heart now well we talked
to fee would you want to look at the
round eight game I'm gonna ask him about
it well I mean there's not much to ask
it was just nice yeah I would be like
nice we can say that so
rocket Omaha row he drew this glass cake
yeah two and a half for the day so five
points still a good day yeah absolutely
and an epic win in round eight and his
his first win let's pull up his first
win cuz I don't remember it off the top
of my head so he started off strong with
a win against drumroll please
here we go back in round 7 yeah okay
against slim Bell hoja so now this was
before we took to air today yeah so when
we got here this had already happened
and some of the familiar ideas we've
been talking about since we started
covering this tournament right a lot to
do with Bishop trades for Knights and
how they're supposed to damage the pawn
structure especially if you can follow
up with a bishop trade that will take
away your opponent's bishop pair so h6 a
good idea preventing the exchange of
bishops and let's see how white
what about creating the attack here look
at this king f7 King g6 not how you
usually get your King to safety but if
you get tape seven might actually work
so now we're preparing some 95 nine
takes e5
see for kingi a booth what is going on
here see four kings yet oh so g5 is pain
cakes thanks
what do we have on the line we are still
connecting here yeah
though we will have fewer Kodama Haro ah
yes we have them right now we take a
moment just to chat you have one of our
players in this event fee it's nice to
talk to you for the first time welcome
to the studio and it's a pleasure to
have you
so you had a really great day out of
three
tell us about your thoughts in general
just on the day because yesterday I made
the hull out of three so I was happy but
two out of three even if I was a bit
lucky and the last game was in I think I
mean it was not really losing but I had
a bad position but I managed to defend
at the end so you have really come of
age in an era in chess where rapid and
blitz is really becoming more prominent
on the world stage
and that's what this tournament is all
about do you prefer playing on a big
stage like this do you prefer classical
or do you prefer quick chess
[Music]
well we were yeah we were talking about
the the ratings and how they might be
misrepresentative and I jump in ask a
couple questions ASCII I fee this is a
grandmaster robert on gaskey we were
following your your game along and i was
wondering where did you feel like your
position got a little bit out of hand
because it seemed like you trade it off
White's dark square bishop which is
generally a good thing in this line but
but then maybe your your e6000 was a
little bit weak so whenever white plays
c4 it looks like you might have some
trouble defending e6 round number nine
yeah oh no yeah the round of the game
you just played right now yeah yeah you
said you said you felt like you you
might be losing at some point okay yeah
I mean it was definitely an unpleasant
position in the middle game but you held
well and I also wanted to congratulate
you on your nice tactical win a round
ago you had that double bishops
sacrifice a nice tactical theme you
don't really see it that often but it's
a great combination so congratulations
and also congratulations on a very good
day because you are making a good
comeback from you know half out of three
yesterday two and a half out of three
today so good luck in the blitz portion
thank you and if he before we let you go
we've been chatting about it you know
the the main players in this tournament
we've got to know how to say their names
correctly so how do you say your last
name my last name is
[Music]
alright ok we'll we'll learn to willing
to say it will learn to love it but see
also how do you prepare if you're
preparing at all for the Blitz games
ahead in the next two days but ok I try
to analyze my all my games all my repeat
games yeah I think that's my preparation
during my last games alright well thank
you very much for joining us and we'll
let you go and get some rest for
tomorrow the Blitz day remember number
one thanks
all right have a good night all right
calling from the Ivory Coast that is
fever code Omaha row living in Paris
playing for his homeland of Madagascar
excellent and I think that maybe his
youth will contribute to a difference in
stamina perhaps with some of the other
players in the field well young people
love quick chess right right yeah so and
he's too clearly the youngest in this
field but there's no chance oh hey look
who we have now on the line the leader
of the tournament going into the Blitz
days grandmaster dr. Bassam Amin from
Egypt bossom great day for you did you
expect to to have the success that you
did today coming in I was quite lucky in
the first two games okay I think in
first game
after he sacrificed his piece for three
poems and I think I should have played
for a meet at some position and I pass
exam moment I played Ross III miss
something here I mean he played Rose III
and I played Bishop c2 c5 and I'm sure
there is some something to win here but
I couldn't find them okay I went to this
end game with Miss Agnes two pawns and
it was very difficult but it's okay I
know he was short on time also so I
managed to trick him in time crusher
much to him and then second game against
Kenya I think oh oh it looks like we
have lost call unfortunately let's try
to get him back on the line we've had a
pretty good record so far with keeping
butterfingers alright we're we're
reconnecting here okay we have him back
all right and I possum this is a this is
Robert I also wanted to congratulate you
on your perfect game and personally what
I thought was your your best game of the
tournament this last name the most
recent one that you know that you want a
very nice combination with the Bishop f3
check and then Bishop takes me for
leaving your queen unprotected on before
it seems to be a theme for you in this
tournament to be sacrificing your queen
it seems but it's working out pretty
well
exactly but luckily so so that was a
pretty much of forced win at that point
because it sure looks powerful right
after a Bishop to f3 check because then
if I play same lines and I don't have
this rupee one and in the end yeah yeah
and what were you gonna do against King
g1 so I thought okay at least I have
option to take on d4 first no yeah check
check so if he takes back by root guy
gets this Queen b3 okay and he can't
take the Queen because it forced the
rose and then it was hanging mm-hmm
okay so that makes sense so so with the
King on g1 you have this in-between move
Bishop takes d4 check it seems to yeah
create a lot of problems and if they
ship takes d4 well the Queen's not
hanging anymore so okay yeah so it looks
winning anyway so a very nice
combination to cap off a very good day
yeah it was a good thing and it's good
to don't have to point it before the
bids because it is sitting more rooms to
play so you know you can see what
happens so it's good to have some some
points to make this when it comes to
this format and starting with three days
of rapid and then the two days of blitz
what is the general mood in the
tournament hall is everyone really
anticipating the blitz rounds or are
they dreading them well yeah I think
there is less stressing in a way I mean
okay no against itself is this very
stressful of course with so limited time
on time pressure and so on but you know
at least you don't have to do so much
preparation as you could be doing for is
a Rapids because okay dancing I was just
playing goodness what matters and
playing fast sometimes but rapid you you
you do have to play seriously in the
game and these specials opening and you
have to prepare because okay I think
it's just a bit easier to play and you
just play and you go on say you don't
have to prepare so much all right well
possum thank you for joining us here on
the show and we wish you the best in the
upcoming blitz rounds all right Egypt's
own the African champion dr. Fossum Amin
or Sawyer yeah what is it what a great
day this has been
we've had we had some surprises but the
anticipation for the Blitz rounds is
what's really getting me let me ask you
something
yeah here bossom
and you seem to be like sacrificing your
queen or blundering your queen you know
the the line is very thin
do you go for Queen trains in the Blitz
portion or because you know he's having
some trouble with his Queens but like
today it was a very good sacrifice but
he's also winning a lot so do you stick
with your guns were you saying hmm let
me get these Queens about quick right I
don't know I mean there's so many
different rules of thumb and general
philosophies that are running through my
head from resonate grandmasters over the
years been Feingold Street screaming
never trade never trade never trade but
then also he's bossom is ahead a few
points yeah so whatever he's doing it's
working yeah oh yeah I would I would
stick with my guns his idea is basically
when I got from that interview was let
the chips fall where they may and the
Blitz because it's so crazy I mean
preparation for blitz just get a good
night's sleep right I start swinging
right you know that's what it is it's a
slugfest and it's gonna be right here
just 24 comm starting tomorrow we can't
wait but let's take a look at the
standings after all of the rapid rounds
have been completed
remember these scores were two points
per game on the line so a possible 18
points has happened and Fossum Amin he's
at the top leading by two points this
blitz stage will only be one point per
game it's gonna be normal scoring there
I say so what do you make of these
standings after the Blitz I'm sorry
after the rapid portion well I think
that the standings are still pretty I
mean
Amin has a lead but not by much
considering we have 18 points up for
grabs it doesn't seem like two points
should be anything to get too confident
about
because you know you have a bad day when
you have nine points up for grabs and
you score maybe like five someone can
easily catch up right with a two-point
differential and also we see that from
second place there is a difference of
two points as well between second and
third and fourth so even there
not a big difference we we have a lot to
see and another thought you know this is
an abbreviated show when we go on the
air tomorrow seven rounds of blitz will
already have been played ok ok so we
might be looking at something completely
different that doesn't resemble this but
we'll have to see
it might look just like this with just
different numbers tomorrow the rounds
themselves begin at the same time I'm
talking the games themselves in the
Ivory Coast will begin at 3 p.m. local
time however here we're gonna be
starting at a completely different time
1815 UTC and that's ivory coast time as
well and we in in st. Louis central time
in the u.s. we will be on the air at
that's 1:15 p.m. so just a little bit
later and we will be on the air in time
to cover the last two rounds of blitz so
I should not show up at 3:00 please
don't okay so we will see you tomorrow
at 1:15 p.m. Central time here in the
States so this production was produced
was that what really this this was
produced by the world's greatest
production B team
Tammy Hyde is the technical adviser
Isaac's rants his graphics and audio
your technical director is Dennis LaRue
I'm Ben Simon I'm Robert and gaskey and
until tomorrow it's gonna be blitz we
say let's so long from the show-me-state
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you